[Musique]
prenons le temps de nous regarder
bouquet de couleurs de culture de
croyants la france est comme d'autres
grandes nations du monde un pays mais
les regards dans les paysages des
territoires de france et d'outre-mer
naturel ou façonnés par nous ils sont
une aide comparable university laisser
s'épanouir les identités et respirer les
libertés locales peuvent rire nous
retrouvailles dans la citoyenneté en
assurant l'égalité des chances et la
solidarité pousses telles sont les
missions premières d'une république qui
vous respecte je crois que la république
les politiques se doivent de favoriser
l'éclosion pour les entreprises qui sont
créatrices d'emplois et par des moyens
très simples mais qui donne plus
confiance à ses jeunes créateurs car il
suffit pas d'avoir une idée moi
l'égalité des chances je crois pas aux
échos faire partie de la société
française maintenant fois marin travail
alors forcément tchèque du travail et
pour trouver travail par un petit garçon
il a pas de crèche et je trouve pas
normal du tout aux musiques ya des
listes d'attentes comptait pas les
lignes d'attentes pour la crèche c'est
dénué d'atouts pour le logement
alors à quand comptez si vous voulez que
je pourrais faire partie de cette
société
l'égalité des chances ce n'est pas un
fait est une exigence jeu là déclare dès
la petite enfance avec des crèches
gratuites et comme l'école maternelle
pour donner toutes leurs chances à tous
les enfants dès le plus jeune âge aux
inégalités de nature donné tentes de
fortune de situation
l'état doit avoir l'ambition d'assurer
l'égalité des chances par l'éducation en
donnant plus et mieux l'ancien militaire
par le logement un logement pour tous et
la capacité à la propriété et par
l'emploi une autorité indépendante de
lutte contre toutes les discriminations
liées aux origines ou telle orientation
sexuelle ou handicap devra veiller au
respect des lois pour les améliorations
utiles et accompagner les victimes de
cette discrimination dans leurs
démarches des pompiers judiciaire
l'égalité des chances c'est aussi des
procédures plus souples plus efficace
pour créer des activités et donner à
chacun les moyens d'aller jusqu'au bout
de ses rêves il en a la capacité
le système bancaire devrait être réformé
ans
la frénésie sécuritaire de n'entendre
parole publique les traiter elle a
laissé fuir la lucidité et la générosité
il ne revient pas aux responsables
politiques par des discours et le dec
été fouettée a rapporté dans l'apple les
compressions de la loi doivent être
sanctionnés que leur auteur soit
puissant ou misérable
j'accuse les pouvoirs publics d'avoir
déserté les quitter les zones rurales et
d'avoir livré les populations
vulnérables aux bandits ou tide
je réclame le retour des cabines
publiques de tous les services publics
dans l'équité et les zones rurales et
lors qu'il arrive à nos enfants de
trébucher je veux leur dire que nous les
fonctionnements pour les aider à grandir
mais que nous continuons à les aimer et
à leur tenir la même pour les
accompagner sur leur chemin de vie
parler de démocratie en côtoyant un
milliard de pauvres dont 93 sont deux
femmes deux millions de chômeurs dont 50
% de femmes
comment tolérer que 30% de salaires sont
versés en moins du seul fait d'être
femme vous instruire en outre des
merveilles du respect de la confiance
nous en pondre on a nourri les chemins
de l'exigeante nous leur enseigneront à
tous les secrets de l'audace pour
adapter leur part à la conquête de monde
aux couleurs de leurs rêves la diversité
tant nous comme elle est dans la nature
une république laïque qui respecte nos
identités et protège les institutions
publiques de toutes les influences une
république moderne qui entre
lien social dans la confiance une
république fraternelle exigeante sur la
solidarité est transi jantes sur
l'égalité des chances
voilà bien pour notre avenir commun la
plus belle des promesses
[Musique]